time for another episode of just getting
started this is episode 8 in our voices
of the nfl series on this origin podcast
and i am thrilled to be joined by
someone who i'm also thrilled to be able
to call a good friend a frequent guest
on my daily rich eisen show and i have
known her for every single year that
i've been with the nfl that means 18 and
counting long time
front office executive ceo and president
of the oakland raiders back in the day
now of cbs sports amy trask how are you
amy
i am well and i am absolutely thrilled
to join you today you've referenced the
number of years we've known one another
and notwithstanding that there were
often issues that flared up between and
among those with whom we interacted you
and i have engaged in the sort of civil
discourse and relationship
everyone should engage in and we have
when we have disagreed we have done so
agreeably and i have been a fan of yours
since i met you
likewise amy trask although i will share
with the audience out of everybody who
has been on this podcast uh you are the
one who when i first met
scared the [ __ ] out of me
okay i kind of like absolutely scared
the [ __ ] out of me i remember it was
again it was our first owners meeting
for the nfl network back at the breakers
hotel if you recall this one back in
2004 calendar year and i just remember
you walking into the room with al davis
and the old what was it is referred to
as the oneplus one right owner plus
team exactly it was the two perc
right a two per club meeting they had
the one per clubs which could either be
an owner or his design or the two per
club which was an owner and one other
person right and you were
frequently the one other person from the
club
and i just remember and i just want to
start with this before we get into how
you got started
this is interesting like the the concept
of how we got started to start this
whole thing off i will never forget i
want to describe this to people
an owner's meeting or membership meeting
as it's known in the national football
league
there's like this
there's this um
construct and i don't know if it's that
way anymore of the way that the tables
were set up it was kind of like the
letter e
where there were the the the
the the top and the bottom of the letter
e and then the middle part that makes
the letter e which is where all of the
members would sit
and then the long part of the e that
connects all the arms is where the
league executives would sit
and if i'm not mistaken
al davis and the raiders and you would
always sit and the if it if this is the
letter e right here you would always sit
on the end of the letter e and out that
was al's seat
and that was it and i was just like whoa
okay this is i don't know why that blew
me away it just got me it was wild that
it was your seat period end of story
you know
well rich number one
i'm kind of delighted i i terrified you
and i'm gonna own that and people are
gonna hear about that i was not known as
the princess of darkness for nothing and
by the way when people within the league
ascribed to me that nickname and shared
it with mike silver who included it in
an article it was not intended as a
compliment at all to the contrary well i
embraced it raider fans embraced it and
i shall forever cherish it but about
that letter e in the seating something
that stumped me throughout my career
every single meeting over my almost
30-year career from the time i started
attending those meetings with al my
first year with the team until the time
i left every team sits in the same place
so i constantly said to league officers
league officials
why can't we just assign them so we
don't have to get there at five in the
morning to put our names on the seat on
a little pad but it just never happened
and so you know you had to get there
really early to save your seat but
everybody sat in the same seats anyway
so i know right
i was just fascinated by the same seats
policy in that regard where um the
giants and the steelers would always sit
next to each other because the rooney's
and the mara family and thus the name of
the
famous actress rooney mara
would sit next to one another
all the time but al always had he said
you just sat right at the end there
and if i'm not mistaken most of the time
abstained
right always it was was there's a lot of
obstacles
amy back in the day i'm kind of proud
that i'm the one who got him to stop
abstaining and there's a funny story
associated with that when i joined the
every vote was abstain abstain abstain
abstain because of course the league had
sued the raiders and there was
litigation involved and al didn't want
to be on the record as a yes or no and
then even after that he continued the
practice of abstaining and i finally
finally after years of prevailing on him
convinced him we were going to vote yes
or no and so the first time after we
stopped abstaining a vote came up and i
voted no and one of the
representatives of another team looked
at me and i said bet you wish we were
abstaining now
ah that's fantastic because i did ask
that oh of i forget who because we were
when nfl network first started
they allowed the cameras in there and we
would just
run on nfl total access at night from an
owner's meeting sort of
unvarnished you know obviously it did it
did go through some vetting
but sort of like we would call it nfl
c-span it was kind of like showing the
machinations
and how the sausage kind of gets made
and i would sit in the back of the room
and i did i forgot who i asked like why
do the raiders always abstain and i
can't believe i'm finally getting an
answer now 18 years later this is
awesome and the executive who got so
annoyed at me or made the face i
shouldn't say so annoyed but made the
face when we voted no was one of the
executives of another team who was
constantly
chiding me and i mean that in a
good-natured way a fun way of why do you
always abstain vote yes or no vote yes
or no stop abstaining so when i finally
convinced al that we shouldn't abstain
and voted no i looked at him and as i
said i said bet you wish we were
abstaining now but rich i remember you
in the back of the rooms and i remember
those cameras and i don't know if you
remember but when i saw those cameras
rolling i would run so fast in the other
direction that people would tease that i
was going to sign me to play corner
[Laughter]
oh i just remember those days that was
amazing those were way back in those
days so let's let's jump right into it
this part of it amy trask how did you
j how did you get started did you always
want to be in sports management was that
a goal of yours amy no um i grew up and
then even after i had arguably grown up
but maybe wasn't fully grown up wanting
to be any number of different things i
really didn't have a plan and i'll
mention something about that in a moment
but i was
i've loved football since junior high
when i was at berkeley the raiders were
still in oakland which
put them just down the road or just down
the freeway from me and i had the
opportunity to enjoy some games in
person
and i just i fell in love with
everything about the team this was a
team owned by a gentleman who would give
people second chances and third chances
and some people said far too many
chances
he would embrace people that others had
yikes sorry
i'm kind of new to this whole
earpod thing
uh he would embrace people that others
had labeled behavior problems and having
been labeled a behavior problem in
kindergarten and that label stuck with
me through
high school many might argue it still is
appropriate but i love the fact that he
didn't care if you were labeled a
behavior problem if he would
you know come on in and contribute and
if someone labeled you a behavior
problem that wasn't his concern so i
fell in love with that i would watch
games of the raiders playing on the road
and you'd see other teams on road games
and the players would get out of the
team buses and they'd be wearing sport
coats or suits and carrying briefcases
and then you'd see the raiders get out
of the bus and they just rolled out like
god knows where they had been the night
before
and wearing hoodies and sweats and
whatever and they just rolled in and won
so i fell in love with the team when i
was in berkeley and happenstance or fate
the year i came back down to los angeles
which is where i'm from was the year the
team ultimately uh permanently at that
time relocated down here the team had
tried before but been ordered back by
the court and then came down the same
year i came for grad school so while i
was in grad school i heard all these
other people students talking about
internships and externships and i
thought well that sounds kind of fun and
i called the team and said i would like
to be an intern and that's how it
started you called the raiders
i called who did you call
i called the switchboard and i said i'd
like to do an internship for the team
and the person who answered the phone
connected me to someone and if we had
time i would make you play 20 questions
as to the person with whom they
connected me but because we don't
necessarily have that time or that might
not be how you choose to use the time i
will tell you it was al lokasal
and i talked to him and he said
no it was it was
one of the most famous and i said
what would you say it's like it like al
davis davis's most famous right hand
i guess fixer friend you know executive
some might call him a henchman
[Laughter]
so i
the
the uh switchboard and by the way it was
my pleasure to work with him the
switchboard operator connected me
through to al locasal and i said i'd
like to do an internship and he said
well what's that
and i said well i'll work for you
and you won't have to pay me and he said
okay come down
and i do want to note really quickly
rich because this is important it's
important to me
i recognize that not everyone
has the luxury the fortune the
opportunity
is able to do an internship for no pay
so i understand that it was my
tremendous fortune that i was able to
say to the raiders i'll work for you and
you don't have to pay me and i get it
not everyone could do that the good news
is today nfl teams do pay their interns
not so much back in the day but i drove
down and i met everybody and i was in
law school at the time so i started
interning in the legal department
how do you banish high rates on car
insurance you switched to geico during
geikoen
i do like making that sound by the way
i'll do it again
october is geico's favorite time of year
people and geico has been working even
harder to cast out high rates on car
insurance and craft just the right
coverage for you and your family but
here's the thing you may not know about
geico they could also help you uncover
more savings when you bundle the other
things parked in your driveway like your
beloved motorcycle boat or even home
away from home your rv geico could even
help you save on homeowners and renters
insurance so visit geico.com today and
you'll see firsthand that switching your
insurance coverage doesn't have to be
scary the only thing that will haunt
your nightmares is seeing just how much
you could have saved if you had switched
sooner geico 15 minutes could save you
15 or more on car insurance happy
geicoween
[Applause]
[Music]
this is amazing
did you know you never thought like what
a waste of time just to call the
switchboard of the los angeles raiders
and offer my services to join in
whatever capacity they saw fit right i
mean like there you never thought what a
crazy idea i don't want to be rejected i
don't want to be told no i'm just going
to say forget it that never crossed your
mind
well first of all what's the worst that
could have happened the worst thing
would have been they would say no
and then i would have been in no
worse a position
than i was at the time meaning if they
said no i wouldn't have an internship
but i didn't have an internship when
they called them
so why not give it a try
and i didn't care in what department i
would intern i would do anything and
everything and i did do everything in
anything i was interning in the legal
department but i walked all around the
organization and i went into other
departments and i helped alphabetize the
will call tickets in the ticket
department and i helped file things in
the scouting department anything i could
do i was thrilled to do
when's the first time you met al davis
when did that happen
uh it was during my internship as i
mentioned the league had sued the
raiders uh relating to trans uh
franchise relocations and that that
lawsuit was still pending and i was
dispatched someplace to go look through
some records and and when i say
dispatched i'm using that in sort of a
intended to be silly way but i went to
do some legal research and when i
concluded the research and came back and
you know al was aware i had gone he was
on board with sending me to do it and i
did it and that's how i first interacted
with him i think so where okay then
did you meet with him and tell him
you're like when when's the first time
where you really
just truly sat down and he got to know
you amy trask and
potentially started thinking about
something other than an internship for
you
okay
it wasn't a sit-down it was a different
encounter as i said both as an intern
and then when i joined the well i'll
come to that minute but as an intern and
even when i joined the organization on
full-time i wanted to learn
everything i could and i wanted to
contribute in every way i could in any
way i could so i would go from
department to department how can i help
is there anything i can do and at one
point someone on staff took me aside and
said you know al is not going to like
this al is not going to like that you're
walking around the organization and
going into other departments and
involving yourself and things he's just
not going to like it and i think maybe
more than one person told me that but i
said okay thanks and i kept doing it
and uh the way the offices were set up i
was in an office on the second floor
just across from al's office we all
shared offices so the legal offices were
up on the second floor as were the
finance offices and the player personnel
offices
and i was walking up the staircase at
the precise moment he was walking down
and we stopped right next to one another
on the same stair and he looked at me
and said where are we on ticket sales
and that told me
one he was well aware i was walking
through the building learning everything
i could going to every department i
could and two that was his way of
letting me know that was okay
because if it wasn't okay
why would he say to me where are we on
ticket sales
i found that to be very encouraging and
i realized two things at the moment
number one
he is not put off by me doing this as i
had been led to believe and two
i better have the answers
so when i ran into him i better know the
answers to his questions and that was a
very significant moment because it was a
suggestion to me that he was encouraging
me to continue to grow and to learn
because he
had you not known the answer
then maybe he would have come down on
you for poking your nose as your
colleagues were concerned he might view
it as such
in places not in your lane to use the
21st century phrase
right like that that it that might have
been
a test that you passed
in the stairwell of the raiders
organization that's a great point rich
and even if he didn't come down on me
for that he might have simply sort of
scrubbed his hands of it and said well
you know she didn't prove herself she
had a chance to let me know the answer
she didn't have the answer and even if
he didn't as you said come down on me i
think it would have been a very
different
moment in time and moment in my career
if you will right so then when did you
go from being clear raider material in
his mind to raider executive material
when did that happen amy how did that
happen when
i don't know that i can point to a
particular minute look i was there
almost 30 years
and i grew
within the job i grew up on the job and
rich i use that in two senses you know i
i joined in my early 20s when i was
first an intern
and then mid-20s when i joined full-time
so not only did i grow up on the job in
terms of learning the job
i grew up on the job so you know i made
a lot of mistakes along the way by the
way and there there's a segway here to
what i'm about to say
one of the biggest misconceptions about
al is that you couldn't disagree with
him
because if that were the case i would
have been fired roughly two weeks into
my job
i was sitting in my office the one i
described across the hall from his with
a colleague and al came in and ripped
into that person like i can only
envision a velociraptor would have
ripped into flesh
and he was really having at it and after
i listened for a bit of time i said
excuse me you're wrong and rich you know
i don't have a dainty voice under any
circumstances but i was also working to
be heard over him and he was pretty loud
at the time so i said excuse me you're
wrong and i will never forget the look
on his face when his face turned to me i
mean it was just i'm like thinking of
his face and the expression right now
and i said he looked at me like what
and i went on to say look if the data on
which you were basing your conclusion
was accurate
well then that's a fair conclusion but
you are basing your analysis and you are
basing your conclusion on inaccurate
information and you're wrong and he
screamed and or let's say yelled not
screamed he yelled and i yelled and he
yelled and i yelled and i didn't know it
till much later but apparently everyone
had gathered outside the office because
they couldn't believe this person that
had been there two weeks
or so was having this argument with al
and one woman actually bought brought
boxes over because she figured out you
know amy get out of here come on no way
oh no dead serious and then towards the
end of the argument you know as the
arguments you know going on and on and
winding that he looked at me and he said
oh
i gotcha
i gotcha okay
and we moved on and over the course of
almost 30 years i disagreed with him
more than i agreed with him so that is
the biggest misconception about al that
he wouldn't tolerate those who disagreed
with him that he wouldn't tolerate
disagreement but what i learned
you don't just disagree to be
disagreeable you come armed with
information
and you make your best argument
and then at the end of the day i
realized
he was the owner of the business i was
not so i could do all i could to change
his mind and if i didn't change his mind
it was my job to do the best i could
with the decisions he made
[Applause]
on the football field everyone has to
play by the rule book shouldn't it be
that way off the field too following a
law enacted at the start of 2021
hospitals have a new set of rules they
need to play by to provide clear and
upfront pricing to patients and unlike a
wide receiver dragging their feet to
stay inbounds hospitals are dragging
their feet to stay out of bounds not
complying with new federal rules for
price transparency help spread the word
to make sure hospitals don't break the
rules because when they do patients will
always lose sponsored by power to the
patients
[Applause]
when was the first time
you encountered
some sort of
miscalculation on other people's parts
in the league
about your
tenure or abilities because of your
gender when was the first time that
happened
with you
no one has ever phrased the question to
me in that manner proving again how good
you are at this no one's ever asked me
about a miscalculation
or a misconception
look rick
i joined the league in the mid 80s
early 80s for my internship mid 80s
full-time that was a long time ago and a
lot of your fans a lot of people
watching this weren't even born then and
i say that you know i kind of want to
cry when i say it but it's to put it
into context
right
so i went into that first league meeting
and i was the only woman there
and i really didn't care
i
i didn't spend a moment
concerning myself
with what other people thought
about my gender it never made sense to
me during my years in the league it
still doesn't make sense to me that i
should walk into any situation any
meeting any anything
expecting and hoping that others won't
focus on my gender
if i'm focused on my gender if i don't
want you thinking about my gender
why am i thinking about my gender and by
the way if you want to be thinking about
my gender go ahead and waste your time
because i'm not going to be wasting my
time thinking about it
and people ask me all the time well were
you tested because of your gender
and i don't know the answer to that
people are tested all the time tested
because of race gender age educational
background ethnicity seniority
but let's assume i was tested because of
my gender because that's a very fair and
safe assumption
well what's the best thing to do when
we're tested
pass the damn test
so that's where i put my energy
did al ever refer to your gender in
terms of your tough for a woman or
anything like that or did he
was he just completely
oblivious
and i say that in only the best possible
term
to it just didn't never entered his mind
you were just who you were you were amy
trask you're the person who called a
switchboard got to alec locasal made the
most here
opportunity knew all the questions
passed the tests argued with him
successfully
um
you know did he ever bring it up
to you at all uh
once at the very very outset of my
career in a manner that made me look
like mona lisa vito i did my mona lisa
veto and my cousin vinnie imitation
where you kind of go like that and then
once in a way that was one of the most
touching moments of my career
very very early in my career
al was going to be deposed by lawyers
for someone who had sued the raider
organization and i knew about this
because our general counsel jeff baron
was going to be going without the
deposition well they were walking on
their way out of the building and al
looked at me and said come on let's go
well i had no idea i'd be going to this
deposition or that anybody would want me
to go to this deposition but al said
come on let's go
so i jumped in the car with them and we
went to this deposition
um this is a fun memory i haven't showed
this with anyone
this uh we go to the deposition and
we're sitting there and al's being
deposed and we're going a couple hours
three hours and it's roughly lunch time
so the lawyer deposing him for the
plaintiff said you know it's almost
lunch time would you like to take a
break and al said no i don't want to
take a break keep going i just want to
keep going and get this done if you want
to bring something in to eat go ahead
and bring something in to eat i don't
want to stop
so the lawyer representing the other
side says oh okay we can bring food in
amy can get us some sandwiches
and al takes his hand and slams the
table and rich you knew he had that
giant ring on so when he slammed the
table that ring
just made a noise and al looked around
at everyone around the table all the
lawyers for all the different parties
and said and pointed at the guy who said
that and said did you hear that did you
hear that there is one woman in this
room
and he just told her to get lunch and al
went on and on about that and then he
looked at our general counsel and said
jeff get the sandwiches
and i sat there like mona lisa vito and
my cousin vinnie it was a very special
moment yeah
wow
no kidding
the other moment if i may take a moment
to share this with you
one of the most special special moments
in my career and this goes to the heart
of your question we were in a meeting in
the raider offices in our large
conference room i had invited in a
business that we wanted to work with i
wanted to get a deal done with this
business and i asked al to join us at
the meeting because i thought that would
impress them or excite them
so i'm in the meeting room with some
colleagues some co-workers the other is
there and al comes in and one of the
representatives of the other business
was a woman so al walks up to her and
very graciously shakes her hand and says
hello and says you know i tried very
hard not to swear in front of women well
i start looking at my colleagues like
what did he just say what did he just
say
and then al goes on and says and if i do
swear in front of you i apologize but i
want you to know i never swear at women
well with this the pen in my hand flips
out of my hand flies down lands on the
conference room table with a thud and al
looks over me and sees the look on my
face i am utterly incredulous and he
says and this is a quote i shall forever
remember and forever cherish
oh amy
i swear at amy
but i don't consider her a woman
and there is nothing he could have said
that could have popped my heart anymore
he considered me
raider's staff without regard to gender
that's amazing
and he did swear at me all along
ah that is amazing amy those are
incredible stories and it just goes
right to the heart
of the matter and before we move to your
your television career now
um what what do you think of the status
of females in the executive wings in the
nfl right now you know the the
the
trail that you blazed how do you think
it's being followed up on right now
that's very generous of you and thank
you i have two thoughts and they're not
mutually inconsistent number one there
has been tremendous progress since i
joined the league as i said when i
joined the league i was the only woman
in the room and now there are a lot of
terrific women in that room jeanne bonk
of the chargers hannah gordon of the
49ers to name just a couple and there
are women on the sideline uh super bowl
champion tampa bay buccaneers had women
coaching and sarah thomas was an
official so yes tremendous tremendous
growth and
what will really excite me is when these
things are no longer newsworthy
i'm asked all the time when something
happens are you excited and the answer
is sure but what's going to be exciting
is when hiring people without regard to
race gender or any other individuality
which has no bearing on whether one can
do a job is no longer a newsworthy
moment so then let's get into that's by
the way remarkably well said as always
um
how
who called you to say you would you want
to get into tv
nfl tv who how'd you get that call
well i'm going to um answer that and
mention why i'm wearing a cap at the
same time because maybe someone can take
something from this to help them
after i made i told my husband as i was
doing that to be or not to be to be or
not to be that until i made the decision
as to whether i wanted to stay with the
organization or leave i wasn't going to
be able to decide what i wanted to do
next so i
gave my notice i told mark davis that i
was leaving the organization and the
next morning i woke up and i looked at
my husband and said i'm a blight on
humanity i have nothing to do
and we laughed and he said good do
nothing for a while if you would like
and i was contacted about joining cbs
sports and i said no and it was a hard
no
and the reason i said no is nothing has
ever terrified me in life as much as
being in front of on a camera if you go
back and look at the home movies from my
family and yes kids we had movies okay
they were like filmed on a little camera
i'm not in them i have run from cameras
since i was a child and i said no to cbs
and i was sitting and talking to a group
of people in my neighborhood and this is
where it takes a village is so important
and as i was sharing that i wasn't going
to do it because no way no way no way
would i ever go on camera a woman that i
know looked at me and said
let it go
and i thought about that and i thought
just because i have always been
terrified of my of cameras my whole life
maybe i should give this a try and rich
the reason i have always been terrified
of cameras is i grew up with and
to this day still have some tremendous
insecurity about my physical
appearance baseball caps have set me
free the reason i am now able to do this
with you is because i'm sitting here in
a baseball cap i did get dressed up for
you though and put on earrings so the
baseball cap is not a sign of disrespect
it's not because i'm not thrilled to be
talking to you i am but it gives me
courage and so the reason i raise all
this is not so much about me and the
insecurities with which i grew up but if
there's kids listening to this or maybe
even not kids and whether they're boys
or girls men or women
sometimes doing the thing that scares
you more than anything in the world
can be a lot of fun so after that friend
said amy let it go
i called back and said okay
i'm gonna do this
my first show at cvs sports network i
said to the producer right before we
went live
i think i'm gonna throw up all over
myself
and he said to me quote
we would get so many youtube views for
that
and bart scott
the former linebacker who was on the
show with me
held my hand under the table
every single minute that we weren't on
camera
he was a teammate
i can't even i will never be able to
thank him enough we were on that whole
season together and he held my hand
literally not just figuratively wow good
for bart um you know your producer by
the way great joke every joke as you
know has a germ of truth in it um so
that she's the producer he or she uh not
wrong uh that would have definitely
gotten a lot of youtube hits but i can't
honestly amy look i i've known you for a
while um i i
can't tell on tv that you would ever
feel that way you're so confident and
you're so resolute and you're so
succinct as well i mean you're you're
excellent at it like you were built for
it
how you are doing your job and what cbs
wants is your
your opinions
and also your gravitas that you bring to
the table and the way in which you
um communicate it
you can't tell
well you are
very gracious and very kind and i will
say this
the cbs sports team has been tremendous
i've been very honest with them about my
insecurities and they have done
absolutely everything they can to help
me in every way they can and the
confidence those producers will give me
in my ear letting me know you can do
this
they really are teammates in the very
best sense of the word and you know look
we're all scared of something right i
mean you could put me in front of a
group of 14 bankers and ask me to get up
and convince them to give me a half
billion dollar line of credit and i'm
like i got this
but being on camera
so look we all have things that
scare us and this scares us and i love
baseball caps and i did put earrings on
for you to get dressed up thank you i
appreciate it and plus if i'm not
mistaken you are rocking the logo of
your television network i am
see they're great teammates they sent me
baseball caps when the pandemic struck
and they asked me would you do
um some tv segments from your home via
zoom
and i knew ooh that means they're not
going to be sending those
the magicians that they normally bring
in from hogwarts to do my hair and
makeup so i said sure i'll do it if you
send me some baseball caps and they so i
said i think i'll do it if you let me do
it in a baseball cap and they said yes
and then i said and i'll do it in one of
your baseball caps if you want so there
you go
hey when was the last time you seriously
considered your dream i mean come on you
used to think about it all the time what
happened i say it's time you and your
dream get back together think about it
you could live the van life and a
totally customized mercedes-benz
sprinter you could tour around all 423
national park sites build a mountain
cabin with your dad or start your own
business really whatever you dream up
and it's a mercedes-benz van we're
talking about so expect innovative
safety features like crosswind assist
and blind spot assist expect amazing
performance and reliability with an mbux
voice command system a five-star dealer
network and an available gas engine it
runs like well a dream so what do you
say head to the mercedes-benz van
dealership and get that sprinter tell
them your dream sent you
[Applause]
so are you still enjoying it do you like
it doing tv i i am as i said doing that
which scares you can often work out
extraordinarily well and i love it i
love my teammates and i'm having a black
okay and you love obviously southern
california we could see it for the
podcast listeners we see the beautiful
southern california sky behind you
outside your window
so i will i will ask you this amy um to
you know bring us full circle here
um your twitter handle is delightful
people love conversing with you
you love conversing with them and the
and high and all of that
um did you think that you'd be
a social media butterfly in any way
shape or form ever at amy trask no
no
when i joined cbs sports
one of the individuals in the i don't
know if it was the pr department or i
think so said how about going on twitter
no no no and i said uh-uh never
happening not gonna happen no no no i
was like khrushchev uh when he took his
hand and slammed it on the table and
said
niet of course he did turn the boats
around and like khrushchev having said
yet and turning the boats around i said
no no no no no and then i eventually did
it and now i'm fairly convinced they
invented twitter for me
they did i mean you're great with the
gifs you know where you're using you
know your uh
your looney tunes and your i love lucy
ones and you're very you're very good at
it and people love conversing with you
they love it you could see in a very
serious note
twitter and i know that's not the only
social media platform that allows us but
it's the only one i'm on so i'm speaking
to twitter twitter allows us to
communicate with people around the world
and i think that gives us an opportunity
to connect with others throughout the
world
and you know my rule for my twitter
village we exchange thoughts in a
reasoned and reasonable manner and when
we disagree with one another we disagree
agreeably and rich i will tell you in
the time i've been on there have been
about 10 instances in which someone has
disagreed with me in a really nasty
manner and i've written back and said
you know what fair enough you don't
agree with me but you don't need to be
mean about it of course sounding like an
eight-year-old saying you know you don't
have to be a meanie
and in each but two of those instances i
think roughly two the person has written
back and said you know what you're right
i do disagree with you but i didn't have
to be nasty or mean
think we can do collectively if we reach
out to other people around the world
and communicate with civil discourse i
agree there's no question about that
um
i know i've tried i try my best
how do you think the twitter account at
real al davis would be doing do you
think would he without what al i've ever
done at real al davis what do you think
what about that okay okay so
um there was a moment we had where he
was very very annoyed at me about
something um we were having an argument
we were disagreeing in our way where we
would disagree as i said we disagreed
more than we agreed over those almost 30
years and he made some sort of quick
comment to me about um well you can tell
our people to go twit this because
that's what he thought twitter was you
didn't say tweet he said he knew of
twitter so he said they can just twit
this
and i made a comment to him about well
we'll get you your own twitter account
and you can tweet anything you want and
someone else who is in the room with me
took his device which i think we all had
blackberries at the time and under the t
under the table this was one of our team
lawyers he uh and i don't want to say
the word he used on your podcast but you
know exactly what it was he said i'm
going to register it right now at ah
you know what always used to say rhymed
with truck ah truck only it wasn't truck
so here i am angry at alan saying we'll
get you your own twitter account you can
tweet it and i get this email under the
table that says i'm registering it right
now
i've got one last request for your story
and then two final questions for you i
need the story about uh darth vader
coming to the field at the black hole as
part of i guess some sort of
what um some sort of marketing campaign
promotion or whatever can you please
tell the story about al davis meeting
darth vader please
for my
podcast yeah we um
and i i want to quote him so can i swear
on this podcast please please yes
absolutely go please okay
so we did a promotional you know an
in-game sponsorship with um the
production company for the movie and
they were advancing the movie and look
there was obviously a great synergy
there between darth vader and and star
wars and the raiders so here we were
it's pre-game we're all running around
we're doing our thing and the um
darth vader's on the sideline
al's watching the team warm up and i
walk up to him and i said i need you to
say hello to darth vader he's here with
part of our sponsorship i need you to
greet darth vader and al says to me
quote who the [ __ ] is darth vader close
quote
but that wasn't even his tone i'm not
doing it it was like who the [ __ ] is
darth vader but
he knew i wouldn't have asked if it
wasn't important to me to the team to
the sponsorship to the relationship so
he went over and he shook darth vader's
hands and that picture is a classic it
is it's to this day it's just
amazing oh my god so he truly had no
teddy never seen star wars al davis
never saw star wars look all right it
was honest it was sincere he wasn't
messing around just he look i'm bugging
him during pre-game warm-ups to leave
the sideline and to introduce you know
to say hello and greet darth vader
so yeah that was sincere well i i guess
if darth vader if darth vader ran a
4-3-40 and could take the top off of
defense he didn't know exactly what
darth vader
you drafted him you know it drafted him
in the first round oh my gosh all right
so two last questions for you one that
i've been asking everybody on this
podcast which we'll finish up with but
one that i have not asked anybody else
because nobody is considered
a viable candidate for this sort of
thing on your twitter feed amy trask i
see what people ask you
and i've known you for as i'm
established 18 years you know the nfl
inside and out you love it and you're
also
masterful in your job currently right
now communicating and know the politics
of the league
people on twitter ask if you'd ever be
someone to consider being the next
commissioner of the nfl obviously that
job is occupied
um but if that ever comes your way would
you be interested clearly you're also um
in the management team uh for big three
basketball right now with with cube
so would you
would you ever be interested in
something like that
amy it is tremendously um
i don't know the word it's very very
flattering when people ask that it
touches my heart sometimes i respond in
a teasing manner saying well are they
going to move the league office to
malibu
sometimes i respond very very seriously
but rich the answer is i am so thrilled
with what i am doing now cbs sports cbs
sports network and as you mentioned
working with cube and jeff with the big
and clyde drexler with the big three i'm
i just love
what i'm doing now so it's not something
that i give any thought to doing okay so
then last question for you
best piece of advice i've asked this of
everybody what's the best piece of
advice
you've received and from whom
amy trask it goes back to when i was a
very very very little girl
and it was from my mom
and she said to me to thine own self be
true
and as moms can do
she told that to me over and over and
over again and as teenage girls can do
uh because she was still telling it to
me when i was a teenage girl even though
she started when i was a very very very
little girl she was doing it when i was
a teenager she's done it my whole life
to thine own self be true and during
those teenage years which i was just
noting i would roll my eyes at her
because that's what teenage girls do
but the fact is it's the best advice
i've ever received
as a footnote rich i will admit to you i
will share with you that it wasn't until
i was in college that i learned that
that was from shakespeare and then my
mom didn't invent that phrase she was
actually quoting from shakespeare but
that is the best advice i've ever
received in my whole life and i credit
my mom not shakespeare because it's my
mom
and rich
the the things i regret
my biggest mistakes
um my biggest bumbles stumbles
errors in judgment have been when i've
tried to be someone or be something i am
not
best advice ever to thine own self be
true and just hearing your story here uh
i guess
cold calling the switchboard of the
raiders and
telling al davis he's wrong and you know
staring him down when he's in a meeting
where he says he doesn't curse
at women i mean
right those are just examples of you
following that advice i would imagine
right there
right i think that's right and if i may
just add this
my mom also
no dainty voice there
but one day some number of years into my
career in a very very soft quiet voice
my mom told me
how much she admired and respected al
davis and her voice was different than
any voice i'd heard her use
and i asked her why and my mom graduated
college with a degree in chemistry
at a time when she was the only woman
graduating with a degree in chemistry
and people weren't hiring women to be
chemists
so that which al did in hiring me
without regard to gender
resonated with my mom when she told me
she was a fan of his i knew it wasn't
about man-to-man coverage or the
quarterback must go down and must go
down hard it was because al afforded me
the opportunity without regard to gender
that she wasn't afforded amy trask you
the best thanks for doing this podcast i
greatly appreciate it thank you rich amy
trask right here on this episode of just
for sports fans fall stands for football
whether it's your kid on the field your
alma mater or favorite nfl team consider
the importance of quality sleep for
performance it's a game changer no
matter if you're an everyday athlete or
a pro let's talk about just everyday
people like me
i have a sleep number setting of 60 my
wife's setting is 70. we get to set our
side of the bed to the way we want it
it's just 10 numbers of difference in
terms of our sleep number but in terms
of the way we like our mattress it makes
the world of difference as for
professional athletes they're at the top
of their game even if they're not
playing in the super bowl or world
series we can look to them for some
pointers like say using blackout blinds
and keep technology away from the bed
ensure the room temperature is cool
which is conducive to better sleep 65 to
67 degrees believe it or not is ideal
for quality sleep nfl athletes are
better at tracking their sleeping habits
with a sleep number 360 smart bed with
sleep iq technology they can monitor
things like restful sleep and heart and
breathing rate so they have a better
sense of what's going on while they're
not awake i think you get the point let
sleep number help you out because proven
quality sleep is life-changing sleep
save up to a thousand dollars on select
sleep number 360 smart beds and
adjustable base plus special financing
for a limited time only at sleep number
stores or sleep number dot com slash
eisen subject to credit approval minimum
monthly payments required see
sleepnumber.com for details
[Applause]
[Music]
amazing amazing person amy trask is just
the greatest and i i i'm not lying i
mean when she would walk in next to al
davis into that room of the owners and
the membership it was like game on like
they walked in like bad asses
and i remember just trying to learn the
league and who was who i certainly knew
who al davis was you know and i
certainly knew how he felt about the nfl
and they would walk in like they were
owning the place and they were just not
to be trifled with
and one of the last times i i you know i
got to know amy and really
connected with her on on a level like an
intellectual level
as i tried to keep up with her
and um
and she you know viewed me as even
though i was the host of nfl network and
thus an extension of the league
that al had been battling with forever
that i was somebody who respected
everybody and was
somebody um
uh
who
could be viewed as um
a i mean i want to say a friend but i
did i definitely felt like she was for
the first time i met her even though i
was scared shitless
and and so
i just remember
the last time i met al davis at an
owner's meeting it was after the league
the nfl network had put together
like the top 20 or top 30 as a countdown
of the top
i forget 40 or 50 whatever it was for
the might have been for the
40th anniversary of the nfl or something
of the super bowl or how to be that that
and um yeah for super bowl 40 they did
the top 40 super bowl champions of all
time and the la raiders were
were not ranked nearly high enough for
al davis's liking and i was at the
owners meeting
and
where it had just announced where the la
raiders were and he came up to me was
using a walker at the time
late in life
and he lit into me you know not yelling
but very demonstrative pulling me aside
like it was my doing that the la raiders
were not nearly ranked as high as he
wanted to be and you could see amy was
kind of standing next to him letting him
have his say with me because
she had this look on her face kind of
like just just hear him out you know
like a she
heard it
enough and she was just ready to have
him share that with me because she had
heard it from him and that look that she
gave me on
her face was just like this is al and
you're part of the nfl and al's one of
the owners and that's it
and you know
i just remember the look on her face as
we they walked away sort of like see you
later
that's how you just got davis you know
and al just being a guy at the combine i
remember he when we first started
covering the combine he had the same
seats policy just like at the owners
meeting he sat in the same seat at the
combine
right on the 40-yard dash starting line
every single year
next to gilbrant who's now in the hall
of fame one of the greatest talent
evaluators of all time from the cowboys
organization back in the 60s i'm sure he
and al had times together
and throughout
and the third guy was allowed in that
inner circle it was al davis gilbrant
and bill parcells
the three of them now all in the hall of
fame together sharing a bust's gallery
together it was the three of them and on
occasion you'd see some people kind of
walk up to him and say hi like mike
holmgren
got up there and went and said hello to
him and i just thought to myself you
know it's just joking in the nfl network
meeting at the combine like what if i
just uh got in early because i got him
before everybody else and i sat in al's
chair and you shot the camera of him
coming up to me it's sort of like who is
this punk in the chair and the nfl
network brass was like yeah no we're not
doing that
i can only imagine i would have probably
gotten a call from amy trask saying what
the [ __ ] are you thinking
i love sharing these stories with you
i love it and i hope you've enjoyed
everything about this podcast to this
point
more voices of the nfl still to come
including chris collinsworth of nbc
sports and if you've missed any of the
podcasts beforehand chris berman michael
strand aaron andrews kevin harlan joe
buck jim nance al michaels just check it
out
um because they've been just some great
storytelling for you voices of the nfl
here on just getting started this
episode is over
you